would like to talk about the producer
Peter Jameson ok let's do okay okay okay
when hunter Bodine came to me with this
opportunity I told him that I would
undertake it if they would hire Peter
Jameson to produce the movie Peter was a
friend of mine for several decades he
had been a top of the line production
designer he designed swing shift Point
Break Mike's murder weekend at Bernie's
you know every kind of film and Peter
was a movie business old salt and with
tremendous sense of humor and the reason
Bob's new suit has this phenomenal look
because was made for less than five
hundred thousand dollars but it has this
phenomenal look because Peter because of
Peter and I had there was a certain look
that I wanted we've looked at a French
director named shock to me I wanted a
similar look I had Peter study it i had
the production designer study that I had
the cinematographers study it and we
achieved the look that I wanted but it
was because Peter could execute it and
Peter had worked on so many movies he
held my hand because the great question
was after all of this could I really
direct could I really and I can I can't
I can't direct and Peter passed away in
post-production and it was tremendous
personal and professional loss however
in terms of what you have to do I had to
pick up the reins and I became producer
which is something I didn't really want
to do but I did it and it's fine you do
what you have to do to get your movie
done and how did you get yourself to
that point because you talked about
processes and you know overthinking
things or being too much into you know
you know
getting beyond certain points in
someone's life how was that for you
because some people would just throw up
their hands and say well I'm giving up
now he's gone and he was sort of the one
carrying this or that I I've learned how
to feel my feelings very deeply and that
there's a relationship for me in terms
of feeling my feelings and being
functional they go together it's the
suppression of emotion that paralyzes me
so I've you know feel my feelings
certainly you know Peters law Peter's
death still stings still stings and it
will for a long time because he was my
buddy and my creative partner and but he
gone he's not here so feeling that loss
gives me energy we recently watched the
John River stock a piece of forecasts
phenomenal phenomenal and she talked
about losing someone in her life go and
how it really did hurt from each other
that was the last
East in the past that person got all
those jokes they remembered when so and
so did this and that
and I would imagine that's hard because
it's not just not having that person
there but it's also a piece of past be
gone as well but is there's also new
life and meeting new people and I know
no one can replace someone but how do
you find those connections with other
people that maybe they don't have the
history with you what well one thing I
know is that we are all we are all
irreplaceable because we are all so
distinctively ourselves but you get a
new cast you you simply do you must you
have to you know you I mean some people
retreat but that isn't my nature
I don't know I mean I think I've always
been like this I I'm very gifted with
energy I've always had a lot of energy
no I thought you get a new cast yeah you
get a new cast you know the show must go
on
you